you
hello everybody and congratulations on
what's possibly going to be one of the
last videos in this series this is
really kind of the last video I really
want to make there I might add a few
videos as time goes on but this pretty
much is going to mark the end of this
series we've covered everything I really
want to cover the things that are left
is I do want to show one more thing in
this in the script which is what you're
looking at here and otherwise just keep
in mind all of the variables that we've
already brought up and that is how long
the patterns are we going to look at
what is the required similarity that
we're going to allow for what's the
timeframe that will even look back on
patterns what is the way that we're even
calculating similarity all that stuff
that we've already brought up and again
the way that you machine learn this kind
of stuff is you start playing with those
variables and as long as performance
increases in an escalating manner so it
continue it gets better to a degree
that's even better than the previous
change right as long as that is the case
you continue manipulating that variable
until it that is no longer the case and
then you move on to another variable and
I've pretty much the best method because
really a lot of these variables or
there's an infinite number of changes
you could make so that's that and
there's just no way we could possibly
cover all of that in a series I mean
there's it's just it's that would be a
huge huge undertaking so anyway this
just was just meant to be educational
and cover the basics and you guys can go
do as you please from here now the only
change I was going to I was going to
show you guys and what's up here right
now
is the about 99% of our processing time
is spent in this function right here
pattern recognition so there's a couple
of things we can do with this one we
could take this function and write it in
C and then create a Python import for
this using you could do like scythe on
ours so you can use scythe on and scythe
on eyes something you can use you could
literally write it and see and just make
it an import for Python you could use
Jai thon and probably do this quicker
see there's all those options
and there's really a bunch of things
that you can do to speed this up the
other thing you could do as far as
pattern recognition is concerned is do
what we've done here where each each
step of the way we're requiring a 50%
similarity at least for the first 10
this way what's happening is is in the
sport that's really this four loop
that's causing the most trouble because
if the 70 percent similarity is not met
for that pat-pat found to be one then it
doesn't even run this stuff so the main
issue is really this four loop right
here so there's a few ways you could
speed this four loop up one of them is
just to like if this one similarity is
not greater than 50% no need to continue
this one's not great and so each step of
the way because naturally if we leave it
the way that we've had it even if this
is you know a thousand percent different
and this is five thousand percent
different and this is a two hundred
percent different it's still going to go
through everything anyways right so here
we can cut it off right away and you
could go all the way through the entire
30 if you wanted to do that and save on
some processing so just going through
these right here I dropped processing
time by about 50% and so that wasn't too
bad
the other thing you can do is use
different arrays like numpy array or you
can use imports there's an import called
blissed and depending on your race size
that can be better so you can check
stuff like it that out or again put this
entire function C and just import the
function itself so really there's a lot
of options there but I'm going to leave
that to you guys to figure out on your
own so now what I'm going to go ahead
and do is in the background I'm going to
be showing off a visual representation
of all of our predictions and the
outcomes to those predictions so the
thin lines right R are comparable
patterns that we found you should
recognize those the thick cyan line is
the actual pattern that's in question so
you should recognize that so far the red
and green dots represent each patterns
outcome and as such the prediction
either rise
fault right so the rise is a green dot
and if it's fall it's a red dot and then
and that really only means rise or fall
so not the degree at which it would rise
or fall and then that's all averaged
together to create an average rise or
drop which is plotted in that kind of
dark blue plot and then finally we have
the cyan plot which is the actual
outcome and so if you don't know what
sign is that you probably do but it
signs like a light blue so the dark blue
is the predicted outcome sign plot is
the true outcome and just keep in mind
the prediction is really only
directional so it's not attempting to
predict the exact number it's just
directional so if you were trading it as
long as the prediction was to continue
falling you would you know continue
selling and as long as the prediction
was you know continued rise you would
hold okay so that's all that that would
mean so anyway we're going to be putting
that in the background as I discuss a
few things that I consider to be pretty
important to this series like the
disclaimer says in the beginning of
every video and I said in the beginning
of the series the series was for
educational use only now I didn't just
say that
for legal reasons I mean it so first off
you know this program is is very basic
yet you can see already the complexity
that is already coming to us right and
so not as well not only is the field of
triste trading overall very very tough
but quant analysis and algo trading
overall is really difficult and the
competition is very challenging people
are paid million dollar salaries just to
produce stuff like this you know if
people come out of MIT or Harvard or
whatever and they're paid million dollar
salaries just to spend their time
devoting the mathematics and algorithms
to this practice right so that's your
competition
the figure is about somewhere between 95
and 99 percent of traders lose money in
the market period next of those 1 to 5
percent of people that aren't maybe
losing money most of them don't actually
beat the market either so really they're
losing money and taking more risk then
than if they just invested pure in the
market now what I mean by that is if you
compare to say the SP
five hundred growth year today today
today is October 14th 2013 as I'm
filming this and year today
the sp500 index is up 20% so if you just
bought the S&P 500 and held it so say
you bought an index fund like the SP Y
right the spy you be up 20% and if we
included dividends which you also get if
you would have held you up 21.5%
so here today 21.5 percent and you've
done nothing you've done you put in
really no effort besides the execution
of the purchase you've paid one
commission on this basically and you're
left with a bunch of free time right so
despite the name automated trading I've
never met an auto / algo trader who
didn't spend most of their time dealing
with it so it's not like it's a passive
income and everyone interested in
quantity you know like the numbers right
surely must agree that we even just the
one to five percent odds of winning
those are horrible odds right you want
an executed trade or a group of trades
with one to five percent odds unless of
course the you know the outcome was
thousands and thousands of percent if
you got it right you know but that's not
what's at stake right and so so know you
know but yet a lot of people are taking
these 1 to 5% odds and so it is kind of
strange but I get it you know the field
is very appealing it's exciting it's
sexy but when you break it down it's
gambling most of the time so so with
that just be aware of what you're
getting into if you decide to continue
to pursue this exact field all right and
always compare your results to something
like the SP 500 on long term scale right
and you know I recognize I'm not the
smartest guy in the room all the time
and some people really are smart enough
and really do beat the market and make a
lot of money doing it right and but the
problem is most of Quon traders think
that's them right they think they're
smarter than everybody writing it and
soon find out that they're not and and
you know some people are actually just
addicted to the gambling part of it and
treat the markets that way so you don't
want to do that either or you know and
in the worst part is they don't realize
there it's the gambling they're addicted
to all right the rush now all of that
said machine learning pattern
recognition data manipulation that I
mean it's all it's all just fun right I
made this series mostly for fun and to
teach I realize that's kind of silly
sounding to most people they don't quite
understand why that's fun but it's fun
to me and if that's you then you know
what have at it right that's what I was
doing here and if you're that tiny you
know percentage that's just brilliant
and they can make Bank off this then I'm
also happy for you right just just be
smart about this stuff and I was happy
to at least just teach you guys but I
certainly don't want to lead anybody on
thinking that if you do what I've just
showed you you're going to make a ton of
money you're going to probably lose all
of your money if you traded on this
system so please don't do it so along
the lines of it being fun as well uh
this entire series and program was made
by me just straight on the fly have no
experience at all with pattern
recognition when it comes to like a line
I do it a lot with sentiment analysis
but that's a lot different than the
pattern recognition of a line so that
should also shed some light on how basic
this program is and also the possibility
of there's to be something wrong with
this the entire thing was just kind of
made as I went right so I was just kind
of doing it as I went and filmed and it
was it was kind of fun and interesting
but uh it is certainly a very basic
program luckily if you get to this point
and you realize oh my gosh you're right
that's a crazy idea machine learning and
pattern recognition can be used for all
kinds of things and I'll probably have
some more video series coming out for
that kind of purpose I wouldn't mind
doing one on image recognition stuff
like that so like facial recognition and
if you do know machine learning it's a
great skill to have and this the skill
alone can make you a good sizable amount
of income like facial recognition and
not really so much anymore but not too
long ago that would have gotten you like
an instant government government
contract for big huge money more than
you'd make in the market probably so
anyway good skill to have programming as
well overall so
if anything you got that now and I
enjoyed the series hopefully you enjoyed
the series as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support in the
subscriptions and until next time